the gods gave us many gifts one day  you'll know them all this is where we  keep them beautifully who Whitney is  only the fiercest among us even good and  that is not you dying  you will train harder than any Amazon  before 5 times harder 10 times harder  never let your guard down  you expect the battle to be fair until  she is better than even you but she must  never know the truth about what she is  [Music]  [Applause]  what is this who are you  it is our sacred duty to defend the  world where were you hard  you are in more danger than you think  be careful Diana no one else will defend  the Wolfman Emma welcome to Johnny Hall  London be here yeah it's not for  everybody  or maybe not  there anything else you enjoy  [Music]  [Music]  I am Diana Finisterra  daughter of Hippolyta in the name of all  that is good feel rest upon this one is  over  [Music]  Oh yep that's not going to work please  put the sword down it doesn't go with  the outfit at all